welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
complete Guardians of the Galaxy recap
to get you ready for Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. it all started with the
first Guardians of the Galaxy where we
meet Chris Pratt as Peter Quill AKA
Star-Lord who Star-Lord man legendary
Outlaw he was a kid on earth when his
mom died of cancer then he was abducted
by aliens double whammy he grew up into
a cool space pirate flying around on his
ship the Milano complete with a retro
tape deck so he can jam out to his
awesome mix the incredible oldie
soundtrack to these movies he's been
hired to steal some valuable orb
unfortunately some other guys here to
steal too so appears gotta blast his way
out of there with his rocket boots whoa
Quill's working for the aliens who
abducted him the space pirates the
ravagers led by his captain adopted
father the blue alien yondu the villain
is a different blue alien Ronan the
Accuser working for him as another blue
alien nebula and a green alien Gamora
who are both adopted Daughters of the
purple alien Thanos so as Gamora tries
to steal the orb from quill they run
into a talking raccoon and a tree Rocket
and Groot rocket talks a lot always
cracking wise but Groot can only say I
am Groot they're trying to collect the
bounty on quill but after this big
disturbance they're all under arrest in
space jail Gamora has a big Target on
her back because her boss is Ronan and
Thanos are both very bad dudes
specifically the big guy Drax the
Destroyer wants to kill her because
Ronan killed his family but Gamora is
like yo I hate him too I've spent my
whole life forced to be a villain by my
evil daddy Thanos I'm trying to run away
and be a good guy now in fact she has
someone to sell the orb to and they'll
all split the money if they work
together for an epic Prison Break as
part of his Escape Plan rocket said he
needed this guy's prosthetic leg but
turns out he just thinks it's funny to
steal people's prosthetic Limbs and Drax
turns out is a hilarious character
because he doesn't understand a metaphor
takes everything literally so to meet
the buyer our crew flies to a town
called nowhere quill and Gamora start to
fall in love and we learn about Rocket's
tragic backstory where he was
experimented on to be created watch out
for that in Guardians 3. their buyers
this weird guy called The Collector who
explains this is one of the six Infinity
Stones in fact it's the Power Stone
which is very powerful in fact to normal
people can't touch it it'll just explode
you just now Ronan catches up to him
Drax goes to avenge his family but he's
way outclassed gamora's sister nebula
still likes being evil delivers the
stone to Ronin but now Ronin betrays
Thanos and decides to keep the stone for
himself and so it's up to our crew of
Misfits to save the Galaxy they team up
with the ravagers and yondu fights with
the super cool whistle Arrow he whistles
it zips around wow gamara goes for The
Showdown with nebula hey sis you should
stop being evil but for now nebula pulls
a Loki and eats herself out of there and
as they're crashing Ronin ship Groot
grows a protective ball around him is
the tear-jerking moment we are Groot and
sacrifices himself to save his new
friends but Ronan survived too and he's
about to destroy the planet when he's
distracted by Peter Quill challenging
him to a dance-off yes it's so absurd it
makes him pause which is just a
distraction they needed to blast the orb
away from him it's gonna tear quill
apart but they all hold hands to share
the power long enough to blow Ronan up
and the day is saved they give the Power
Stone to xandar where it's totally safe
for now and our unlikely group of
Misfits have become the Guardians of the
Galaxy and good news Groot survived yeah
they saved a twig that's growing back
into baby Groot so in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 the Guardians were hired to
kill this big monster by these gold
people The Sovereign but on top of their
pavement rocket couldn't help himself he
stole more which they do not appreciate
they're rescued by a mysterious space
cowboy who pulls a Star Wars Wars on him
quill I am your father his name is ego
and he's a super powerful Celestial in
fact he is the planet this body's just
navitar he used it to fly down to earth
and knock up Quill's mom so yeah Peter
Quill's got Celestial powers and the
long-lost father he's always dreamed of
it's here we meet a new member of the
guardian's ego's assistant mantis she's
an empath which means she can feel and
control emotions and she and Drax
basically become a comedy duo meanwhile
yondu and the ravagers face a mutiny
from their new leader taserface who
rocket defeats basically by making fun
of his name they try to escape with help
from Baby Groot who is not much help
they're actually saved by craglin
yanda's loyal first mate who brings him
his whistle Mohawk and it's an epic
scene where he decks out all the
mutineers in one go over on ego's planet
nebula has caught up with Gamora she's
still trying to kill her sister but
after she crashes and Gamora saves her
they have a real sister heart to heart
where it's like hey we should hate our
evil dad Thanos not each other meanwhile
surprise ego's the villain his goal is
to assimilate the whole universe but to
do what he needs a Celestial kid to
power the seeds on the different planets
and wow Earth blue Blobby time just then
yondu busts in to crash the party and
reveals that yeah ego is the one who
hired him will to bring him here but
then he found out he was going to kill
quill so he decided not to to kill ego
for good they gotta fly down to the
planet core but just then the Sovereign
caught up to him yandu takes him out by
blowing up his ship but he's okay he's
floating down with his whistle Arrow I'm
Mary Poppins y'all to fight his evil Dad
quiltaps into his Celestial powers and
it's an insane Celestial fight where
quill makes a Pac-Man then it's up to
Baby Groot to squeeze down to the core
to blow up the brain but he really wants
to press the wrong button but when it
comes to it he chooses right and boom
ego exploded yondu saves Quill's life
and it's another tearjerker he might
have been your father boy but he want
your daddy and yondu sacrifices himself
so quill can live oh complicated
character but a good guy after all all
the ravagers fly out for a big funeral
including randomly Sylvester Stallone
and craglin takes up the whistle Arrow
Mohawk but it's got a pretty steep
learning curve and meanwhile The
Sovereign are still hunting the
Guardians they're going to create a
super Sovereign named Adam watch out for
that in Guardians 3 but first it's time
for Avengers Infinity War big bad daddy
Thanos apparently destroyed xandar off
screen and took the Power Stone
basically he's an eco-terrorist wants to
kill half the population of the universe
to restore balance and if he collects
all six Infinity Stones he can do it
with just a snap so the Guardians of the
Galaxy gotta stop him but first they
crash into Thor who takes Rocket and
Groot off on a side quest the rest of
the team goes to fight Thanos Strax is
finally going to avenge his family but
Thanos already has the reality Stone
Drax is way outclassed again Thanos gets
Gamora and she's like please quill you
gotta kill me rather than let him take
me again it's heartbreaking but quill
pulls the trigger but reality Stone it's
just bubbles he takes Kamar out of there
he needs Gamora because to get the Soul
Stone you have to sacrifice something
you love and even though he was terrible
and evil to her he still loved her in
his own way oh bye Felicia throws her
off the cliff and Gamora is dead
meanwhile Thor meets up with space giant
Tyrion Lannister to forge a new super ax
but they lost the handle so teenage
Groot steps in to make one oh living
would handle they teleport to Earth just
in time for the final battle The
Avengers are surprised to meet their new
allies a space tree and a gun rabbit
rocket teams up with the Winter Soldier
Bucky Barnes who happens to have an
awesome metal arm a rock is like oh I'm
gonna get that arm meanwhile on thanos's
planet the other half the Guardians meet
up with the other half of the Avengers
they take the fight to fan knows again
and this time working together they
almost beat him but when quill finds out
Thanos killed Gamora he freaks out
starts punching him wakes up from the
transcribes The Gauntlet and long story
short blows them all up so now Thanos
gets all six Infinity Stones and he
snaps wipes out 50 percent of the
universe our Guardians though are hit a
bit harder it's more like 75 of them and
so in Avengers end game it's only rocket
and nebula who survived to help the
Avengers on the Time Heist to steal the
Infinity Stones and undo the snap they
travel back to Guardians 1 to take the
Power Stone nice and easy but as they're
warping back nebula malfunctions she's
now connected to the same Wi-Fi as her
evil past self she wants her papa Thanos
about the Avengers plan and goes
undercover as good nebula Back to the
Future she hijacks the time machine and
warps Thanos here where he blows up the
Avengers compound the past Gamora talks
to Future nebula like hey we both become
good guys eventually well I'm ready
right now yeah let's go do it so
nebula's gotta shoot her evil past self
which doesn't create the time travel
Paradox it's Multiverse rules Thanos is
still here with his whole Army but the
Avengers did manage to undo the snap so
all our snapped heroes are back he has
the Guardians of the Galaxy here for the
final battle notably quill finds past
Gamora like oh my God baby you're alive
but pascamore has never met him before
kicks him in the balls like this is the
guy I fall in love with so after the
Avengers defeat Thanos Gamora goes off
to find herself or whatever but the
Guardians get a new addition to their
crew because Thor who's been going
through some stuff is like what's up
guys can I get a ride so the Guardians
show up in Thor love and thunder Thor is
tagging along on the guardian's
adventures but he's way stronger than
them kind of steals there thunder pretty
soon he says goodbye to go off on his
own adventure and for Peter Quill it's
like good riddance and there's one last
thing before volume 3 the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special long story
short Peter's Friends team up to give
him a magical Christmas complete with a
present kidnapping Kevin Bacon nebula
gives a special gift to Rocket yes she
got him Bucky's arm and mantis comes
clean with the secret to Peter ego
wasn't just her boss he was her father
too so these two are sisters happy
family time and the game picks up a new
furry friend the psychic talking Russian
space dog Cosmo and with that you're all
caught up ready for Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3. if you like this recap hit
that subscribe button for more of the
best Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]